[Music]
so the interesting thing about the
debate surrounding biological males and
women's sports is that there really
isn't any debate at all
you know a debate involves argument an
exchange of ideas between people of
opposing sides on a particular issue
and this requires each side to have some
sort of coherent point of view and for
them each to present that point of view
in a manner that might be intelligible
to their opponents
none of that is happening with respect
to this issue the side which favors
opening up female sports and locker
rooms to males has not bothered to
launch
any coherent defense of this change or
give any good reason for anyone to agree
with it
other than to scream empty buzzwords
like bigot and transphobes at those who
fail to cooperate with them
carl sagan liked to say that
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary
evidence now it could just as well be
said that extraordinary policy proposals
require extraordinary
justifications in this case there is
both an extraordinary claim
that some males are really women and an
extraordinary proposal that biological
sex should not be considered as a factor
in who gets admitted into women's sports
yet there is nothing approaching
extraordinary evidence or extraordinary
justification
for these assertions there is not even
ordinary evidence in justification there
is nothing those who favor putting males
in female sports have not bothered to
defend their claim at all or to engage
with the
with the points raised by the other side
the points on the other side are
simple straightforward but also powerful
for example here's author abigail
schreier testifying before the senate
yesterday about the so-called equality
act
and raising a number of i think very
pertinent questions let's listen
if your daughter or granddaughter was
the top high school
tennis player in her state and then five
biological boys
suddenly decided at the age of 17 to
identify as female
should she drop overnight to number six
should she lose her college scholarship
to a male-bodied athlete who would never
have qualified on the boys team
does that strike any member of this
committee as fair or just
if a woman in your state commits a crime
should she be put in a correctional
facility with biological males
some of whom are sex offenders some of
whom may have only begun
identifying as female weeks earlier
all of whom could easily overpower her
if a preschool has a policy that only
female teachers may accompany
little girls to the bathroom and your
daughter's male teacher suddenly
identifies as female
ought that teacher to have a legal
entitlement to accompany her
does that strike anyone in this room as
safe or sensible
those are good questions questions that
need to be answered by the people
proposing this stuff
but they won't answer them they have
again nothing to offer
so to illustrate my point let's turn to
a recent article in the allegedly
reputable publication
scientific american the piece written by
child psychiatrist dr jack turbin
titled trans girls belong on girls
sports teams
claims that there is no scientific case
for excluding biological males from
female sports
now this is certainly extraordinary no
case
it's been thought for millennia that
males have biological advantages over
women
that give them the edge in sports combat
and other physical contests
jack turbine insists that there is no
scientific case not simply a weak case
but
no case at all to support this bias
he then spends several thousand words
explaining why except
he never does explain why the actual
article
itself doesn't prove or even really
attempt to prove
the opening thesis here's what it says
instead the article begins
with the lawsuit filed in federal court
by the family of three girls
cis girls as the author calls them in an
effort to make biological females seem
like but one possible type of girl
one variant they're suing the
connecticut association
of schools uh for allowing boys to
compete against girls in track and field
the author turbine attempts to debunk
the premise of the lawsuit writing
quote after the connecticut lawsuit was
filed by the cisgender girls families
one of those girls beat one of the
transgender girls named in the lawsuit
in the connecticut state championship
it turns out that when transgender girls
play on girls sports teams
cisgender girls can win in fact the vast
majority of female athletes are
cisgender
as are the vast majority of winners
there's no epidemic of transgender girls
dominating female sports attempts to
force
transgender girls to play on the boys
team are unconscionable attacks on
already marginalized transgender
children
and they don't address a real problem
they're unscientific and they would
cause serious mental health damage to
both cisgender
and transgender youth now obviously the
fact that
some girls can beat some guys in some
sports sometimes
does not at all prove that boys don't
have an inherent advantage
i'm sure there are some blind people who
can beat some
seeing people in a game of darts but no
sane person would suggest that sight is
not an advantage
in a contest like that the point with
respect to those male athletes running
running track in connecticut is that
they were winning gold silver and bronze
medals with times that would not have
qualified them to step onto the track
against the men against the men against
their fellow males they were sub-par
runners
12th 13th 14th 15th place or worse
against the women they were top
competitors that's the advantage
and this scientific article doesn't so
much as try to deal with that fact
it just ignores the fact as it ignores
every other fact
later on it says quote the notion of
transgender girls having an
unfair advantage comes from the idea
that testosterone causes physical
changes such as an increase in muscle
mass
but transgender girls are not the only
girls with high testosterone levels
an estimated 10 of women have polycystic
ovarian syndrome which results in
elevated testosterone levels
they are not banned from female sports
transgender girls on puberty blockers on
the other hand have negligible
testosterone levels
yet these state bills would force them
to play with the boys plus the atlantic
the athletic advantage conferred by the
testosterone is equivocal
as ke as a katrina karkasi
a senior visiting fellow an expert on
testosterone and bioethics at yale
university explains
studies of testosterone levels in
athletics do not show any clear
consistent relationship between
testosterone and athletic performance
sometimes testosterone is associated
with better performance but other
studies show weak links or no links
and yet others show testosterone is
associated with worse performance
the bill's premise lacks scientific
validity
okay now even if i were to simply accept
this
ridiculous claim that testosterone
doesn't give you an advantage or even
it's a disadvantage
in a physical sport and even if i were
to pretend that there's some relevance
to the minority of women with an ovarian
condition
that gives them more of the hormone even
if i were to accept all of that
and even if i were to pretend again for
the sake of this argument which he wants
us to pretend that
all of the male athletes competing
against women are on puberty blockers
which is not true well let's say
let's just give him all of that it still
would not come close to proving the case
not
men along available having up to 20
times more testosterone than women
also have greater muscle mass large
larger fast twitch muscle fibers
larger lungs larger hearts longer legs
smaller waists
less body fat and this is but a partial
list
all of these physical factors give men a
distinct profound
significant physical advantage this is
why all of the fastest and strongest
people in the world are men this is why
there is no state in the union where the
top female runners have on average
faster times than the top male runners
this is why a decent male high school
basketball player could walk into the
wnba
and dominate without having to try that
hard
it all comes back to physiology and this
article which is supposed to
be providing a thorough scientific case
for allowing males in women's sports
does not deal with any of these
physiological factors
those two paragraphs that i read are the
extent of the scientific case presented
from there
his argument revolves solely around the
feelings of trans athletes claiming that
it will be emotionally painful for some
men
if they're not allowed to compete
against women but this is negated by the
fact that it's emotionally painful for
women to have their privacy and athletic
opportunities stolen by men
at a minimum we have an emotional wash
right
a stalemate with both sides making
emotional claims
now in reality the emotions of the men
are far outweighed by the women both
because
there are a lot more women affected and
because the emotional demands of the men
are far more unreasonable than that of
the women
but even if we pretend again that it's
an even emotional match
still we are left having to fall back on
the scientific argument
as far as that goes as we've seen the
other side really has no scientific
argument
at all which doesn't stop them from
publishing in something called
scientific american and so
that's why the author of this article is
canceled
and anyone who reads that article or or
at least reads the headline which is
what most people will do and what
they're counting on you doing
and it's simply persuaded that well the
article says it in the headline it's in
something called the scientific american
they must have a scientific case anyone
dumb enough to do that
and i fear there are millions of them
also canceled
hey listen hit the subscribe button do
it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated